rohöl haben wir ein boykott wie sie
wissen da sind aber die deutschen fast
alleine da alle anderen sagen wir
brauchen das noch das pipeline öl aber
wir haben gesagt okay wir steigen aus
beim gas ist das natürlich völlig anders
aber ich sage mal so lange ukraine
russisches gas nehmen und an dem durch
geleiteten russischen gas geld verdient
sollte mir niemand kommen mit einer
moralischen position dass wir doch
bitteschön als erste uns von der klippe
zu stürzen haben sie wissen nicht
worüber sie reden wir reden über 6
millionen arbeitsplätze sie werden hier
einen zusammenbruch deutschland bekommen
das fängt beim brötchen becker an und
das hört bei den düngemitteln auf das
hört bei der chemie fängt es an und bei
der stahlindustrie hat es auf sie haben
flächendeckend arbeitsplatzverlust und
glauben sie im ernst sie werden die
deutschen dazu kriegen noch weiter
ukraine was ich gerne mache unterstützen
wenn wir selber indem ein sanktionen
machen die aber das macht er da bereits
im herbst als wenn wir putin jetzt die
glasplatten abschnitt und passiert ja
genau das dann und sagen ja wir sehen
das im moment moment also sollen wir
jetzt darauf warten und weiter in putins
hände begeben und sagen okay wir
sind ihm völlig ausgeliefert und warten
jetzt mal ab um gottes willen vielleicht
tut er dies vielleicht tut er jene ist
dann wir sollten dem kleinen vorhalt
leisten denn im handel die dass wir
nicht die diese verdichterstation
geliefert haben hat ihm natürlich eine
gute ausrede gegeben um zu sagen ich
sage ich mal wo der bartl den most holt
und deswegen muss man ja und so habe ich
heute gast grund verstanden sie haben
nur die ersten den ersten satz zitiert
die haben gesagt wir können das nicht
garantieren wir haben bis heute noch
keine bestätigung dass diese
verdichterstation rechtzeitig kommt und
die muskeln und wer steht der anderen
werden der stellt wirklich erstaunen der
stillstand wenn der stillstand zehn tage
dauert und die die verdichterstation
kommt dann hat der kämen übrigens
erklärt dann wird er auch wieder gas
liefern moment meist nur sagen ausmaße
der kreml erklärt glauben sie ernsthaft
dass was putin heute sagt wird auch
morgen der fasern hat uns vor dem krieg
gesagt der krieg wird es nicht geben sie
die relative sie sagen ich stelle mal
von von von mir aus ab dann sind sie
doch ein selbstmörder wollen sie das
ganze volk in unglück bringen wir müssen
noch alles tun dass putin uns nicht hier
sozusagen
erben bringen und wenn wir ihn beim wort
nehmen sie berichten es bricht ja da
haben wir eine situation die
unbewältigten noch sagen dürfen was
ihnen der kreml erzählt und das gas
daran tut sie auch daran dass sie ein
problem verkennen auch russland hat ein
interesse gas zu liefern nicht aus
geldlichen gründen da da gibt es
erdgasquellen die können sich nicht so
einfach abstellen hat sie können sie
natürlich abstellen indem sie sozusagen
das erdgas verbrennen mit dem klima sehr
viel helfen und deswegen haben sie
natürlich interesse ein gewisses maß
auch zulief aber es geht ja kurzfristig
auch immer druck den russland weiter
ausüben will auf die ukraine auf europas
geht um spaltung es geht darum so dann
sagenhafte anfrage auch mal auch anlass
hat die ukraine anfangen mit dem gast
also ganz kurz das ist doch das was
gerade passiert die debatten den sage
ich mal so ungefähr zehn tagen geführt
werden in deutschland und europa das ist
genau das was putin erreichen will er
will dass wir angst haben dass wir dass
wir nervös werden dass wir sagen was
passiert jetzt dass wir nicht mehr
darüber sprechen wie viele menschen in
der ukraine sterben dass wir nicht mehr
darüber sprechen welche kriegsverbrechen
begeht sondern dass wir uns gegenseitig
kritisieren für die frage was die
energieversorgung bleiben wir einmal bei
der frage kann man mit putin verhandeln
herr zeyer ja ich finde es bezeichnet
gestatten sie mir die anmerkungen sie
sind auch eine ganze zeit lang
umweltsenator gewesen für die spd glaube
ich in hamburg wenn ich das richtig in
erinnerung habe mein eindruck war dass
die spd mittlerweile auch aus diesem
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine ihr
verhältnis zu russland durchaus
hinterfragt hat ich mach mal ein
fragezeichen bei ihnen da dran im
ausblick das dürfen sie nicht als frage
zu sagen ich habe genauso große kritik
an putin wie der andere ich sehe nur und
habe reagiert auf die frage wollen wir
selber abstellen und sagt ja das müssen
sie beantworten wollen wir selber
abstellen ich will mit ihnen die fragen
müssen sich der andrang ist also nur
darum geht es ich will mit ihm eine
diskussion nach vorne führen der
professor vahrenholt weil die frage ist
doch was können wir tun wenn wir erster
anzeichen sie haben wir zu recht darauf
hingewiesen schauen wir mal einfach in
unserem land schauen wir was die basf
meldet was wir von juniper hören was
können wir tun um unsere eigene
volkswirtschaft zu stabil 7 und sie
nicht zu schaden wenn wir genau wissen
dass die energiepolitik der letzten
jahrzehnte zahlreiche regierung unter
der führung maßgeblich von von union und
spd dazu beigetragen haben dass wir eine
einseitige energiepolitik machen und
dann ist der ausstieg hat die fdp
besteht dann müssen wir sind aber jetzt
die einzelnen die deutlich sein sollte
dann verlängere stück jetzt in firmen
gerne an der seite sich daran war
unterstütze ich sie haben wir bitten
bundes haben sich gesagt haben sich
enthalten wir haben ja kann ich ihnen
sagen weil wir keine abgestimmte
position im ampelbündnis haben und die
schaufenster anträge von friedrich merz
die männer nicht immer leicht sagen muss
wir arbeiten also diese abgestimmt bin
gespannt wer lassen auch nicht nach in
der die grenze um das deutlich zu nach
der sommerpause steht sein aber die fdp
diese chance verpasst das muss man ganz
klar sagen wir bleiben da sehr ernsthaft
daran weil es für uns wichtig ist
einfach noch mal die frage ist wie
können wir in diesem land dazu beitragen
das was an versäumnissen passiert ist
das was wir an der herausforderung sehen
volkswirtschaftlich abzufedern darüber
würde ich gerne schon immer gerne weil
wir können uns nicht in die abhängigkeit
begeben dadurch nicht bleibt bei uns
haben wir müssen raus und deswegen auch
schon längst eine abhängigkeit werbung
geben da gebe ich an scharia recht wir
müssen raus und deswegen ist die frage
warum fördern wir nicht eigenes erdgas
wir haben 23 billionen aber die und die
bundesregierung will es nicht fördern
sie will nicht ran weil sie sagt ja da
müssen wir dann ja das gesetz aufheben
das fracking in deutschland verbietet
aber wir nehmen gerne fracking gas aus
den usa das gleiche ist die kernkraft
haben wir diskutiert
und das gleiche ist mit kohlekraftwerken
wir können natürlich auch mehr
kohlekraftwerke wieder aktivieren da
fehlt es mir an der ernsthaftigkeit
dieses thema wirklich anzupacken und am
ende kann man nur hoffen dass wir dieses
ufer erreichen denn wir müssen weg von
putin das ist völlig klar
aber da hilft uns nicht entschuldigen
wenn ich das sage dass wir da irgendwie
mal ein paar beleuchtungen am
brandenburger tor ab zudem darum geht da
das hilft nun wirklich überhaupt nichts
das sind 0 0 0 0 0 0 1 prozent gleich
aussehen heute mal ein bisschen mehr
redezeit verschaffen das war meinte
heute was ich mir selbst noch gefragt
bin ich dafür bekannt ein wenig zu reden
da müsst ihr selbst rein gehen also
na ja die frage ist ja eines also was
tun wir jetzt und wie wer ist
verantwortlich für die lage in die wir
jetzt gekommen sind weltpolitisch und
hier auf nationaler ebene was wir jetzt
tun da würde ich meinem rednern zur
linken anfahren oder zustimmen müssen
natürlich auch diskussionen führen über
fracking über atomkraft kernkraft ist
doch völlig klar und dass gerade der
sieht momentan das lorbeerkranz es kaum
erwehren können der robert habeck ja
eben nicht bereit ist über diesen
schatten zu springen an diesem dogma
festhält als wird es also als
blasphemischen verstoß gegen die die
zehn gebote der grünen aufgefasst werden
das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht also
ist weiß gott nicht so pragmatisch wie
erscheint wir von weiten teilen der
presse gemacht wird herbig sie haben wir
auch noch eine sehr sehr große to do
liste das andere ist natürlich eine
steile lernkurve liegt vor ihnen her
habe ich ein freundlicher zu formulieren
das andere ist natürlich wie gehen wir
mit russland und wir blicken wir auf
russland sie haben eben freuen das wort
gebraucht von den interessen also auch
russland habe ein interesse auch putin
habe ein interesse da bin ich
mittlerweile skeptisch dass wir das so
in der debatte als ernsthaft erkenntnis
stiftende handlungsleitend kategorie
einbringen können ich erinnere mich nach
diskussionen zwei drei vier fünf tage
vor dem überfall russlands auf die
ukraine habe ich teilgenommen als
zuschauer da hieß es ja nie wird der
ukraine überfallen es gab einen großen
vortrag eines sohns geschätzten spiele
theoretikers gesagt dass sich dagegen
das spricht dagegen dass alles spricht
dagegen eher müsste komplett verrückt
sein 24 stunden später war das verrückte
in anführungszeichen wahr geworden also
ich frage mich inwieweit können wir im
umgang mit einem menschen der bereit ist
tode in millionenhöhe im eigenen und
fremden land zu riskieren zu erwarten
dass er für rationale argumente
zugänglich ist und dass er auf rationale
weise eine interessengeleitete politik
für sein eigenes land macht da habe ich
meine großen zweifel dran deshalb glaube
ich vor dieser kategorie also wir müssen
schauen dass wir herrn putin keinen
vorhalt geben etwas zu tun wir dürfen
nicht reizen wir müssen seine
eindrückliche da aber interessen haben
sie gesagt und keine vorhaltungen
interessen oder sogar zulieferer haben
sie momentan das in der ukraine zu
gewinnen er hat interesse an regen stand
by zu führen alles was dort gesagt hat
diese hässlichen reden wo von wanzen
gesprochen wird der ausräuchern will von
fliegender ausspucken will das sind
vielleicht die wahren interessen und
nicht die gaslieferung was ist für die
durch durch die regierung eine sache
wenn wir uns anschauen so sagen wie die
ampel mit der ganzen ukraine thematik
umgegangen ist wir sind immer hinten
dran also egal was passiert ja ihr leib
zu rücken
das ist eigentlich schon sagen jetzt
haben wir ein bisschen diskutieren ja
wie lange wollen sie denn noch
diskutieren also ich meine wenn es zu
spät ist dann hilft ihnen das auch nicht
mehr das gleiche bei der frage wie gehen
wir jetzt mit dem gas um da warten wir
auch darauf was macht jetzt putin um
gottes willen was tut der kreml auch da
haben wir in wahrheit keine strategie
also bei allen fragen man kann ja
unterschiedliche meinung
unterschiedliche positionen haben aber
ich würde mir von dieser regierung
endlich mal wünschen dass es einen
klaren plan gibt wo geht's hin robert
habe erzählt immer viel was alles nicht
möglich ist und wie schwierig das ist
und dann guckt ein bisschen in seinen
instagram und sollte ein bisschen und
das war es dann